you're gay
tony
[Music]
I assume everything
cazaubon in fact you've worked we're an
independent development studio and
we've been one since the beginning has
always been at the start these twelve enthusiasts
who make the studio in a garage
abandonment and 250 but we were joined
by two hundred and fifty enthusiasts too
and that's what allows us to do
incredible projects like microsoft
flight simulator and she pleads
requiem for example 18
de paris you have
to  affinities woods to you
it's our baby to us it's
as an independent studio it's the
first time that we feel it's really
something we're going to say personal
from a team to the  team we
really started from scratch at the start
so you want an adventurous game a
third person accenture and we said to
ourselves that in fact our best chance was to
start from our specificity of French
we are in a country loaded with  burgundy history
and steeped in history we live
every day in  years of walls that are
several hundred years old and it
's something that we handle with
precision and which allowed us to
give the game a really
strong identity and to deviate a little from the
heroic fantasy side and from  Going into
something rawer that corresponds
exactly to the need to build
a story that is anchored is therefore real
to better go into the fantastic and
and into the emotional when it was
necessary
it's really like a big sister  a
little brother is something that
resonates in us that will speak a little to
everyone and so it was really
the starting point a banter friends
cias was therefore the first characters
who were born amy sia the big sister and
her way of apprehending a little brother of
whom she is not the responsibility and
you suddenly she wants to see all the
responsibility
hugo who is a young child who
ignores everyone is a reality
to take charge of a power and  which
exceeds it and how  ent this duo will grow
together is
realized the story much bigger
than what is being realized so
they are the main actors
alas this start-up catherine every
head annoys
friends that so it's a young girl is
healthy not one  warrior therefore the gameplay
of plex and a gameplay more oriented
on infiltration and survival
the goal always being to
outsmart her enemies to survive I am
the rats or human enemies
after amy sia there are times when she will
have to  fight she will have to
face so have
more action-oriented phases more combat-oriented
all these phases there building a
narrative rhythm that comes to serve
the evolution of the character so that its
its relationship to violence its relationship to
the world each time  is nourished by the
variety of its sequences there the context
of the plague was interesting that it
was a vector of emotions and danger
for the children but a
sickness card is never very easy  ident
especially in a video game where you
have to have adversity to be able to fight
against something so we used
the most symbolic representation of
the plague which was the rats
it made a beautiful incarnation of the
disease but for it to be
impressive and that  'we have this
feeling of propagation it
took thousands we had to try
which pours into the east in the
rooms and in the forests to show
the disease which progresses and which ravages
everything in its path so will relay them
be a version
amplified by a disease that is spreading
it is both a threat but a tool
for fun to know that thanks to the
power of hugo thanks to these tools she
herself will be able to use the rats
to progress sometimes but often
going  also having to face up to find
a way to get through them without being
devoured
we write leno chapter a bit like
episodes this impulse that we have that we have
when we watch a series the
transcribing it into a video game was
essential for us it's a
fairly broad writing technique it's really
a global architecture that
punctuates the whole game and of course the
narration comes to stick to that as
closely as possible each time with
different challenge because on the
exploration phases we have all the freedom at the
level of the dialogues and it is because
we know that as soon as the player will
enter a combat phase there he
will be much more focused on what
'he's doing so it's up to
us to think about saying ok what
's important in going to tell it
rather here we're going to let the gameplay do its
thing so all that's done
with kevin finally here it's a
discussion that is permanent over
three years of production of
constantly evolving the game around that here
they maradona they
only
said if you
think you want to do lots of projects
oblige us to have tools that are both at
the forefront  technology but very  s
flexible and having
our n gine team at home, for example,
allows us to go see them directly and
say we have a challenge relating to the game
we are developing and
we need a way to  solving it and
that makes it possible to expect
feats such as the
gigantic hordes of rats that we see
sweeping over the cities in
the east in thrillers or things
like that,
but afterwards we also saw our  weaknesses
in certain places, in particular since
finally we had to realize the
cutscenes which required
very heavy logistics so in fact we
really invested in a motion
capture studio which belongs to us and which
allowed us to have enormous flexibility
in  terms of filming
[Music] that
olivier de rivière our composer
is someone who brings a lot of
things into the game and so they come up
with lots of ideas
and there we're really talking about emotion we're
really talking about how  he doesn't color
scenes
so with music and there
are times when he doesn't release
incredible compositions and look at the
level opposite or the sequence opposite says
hey it's great what he did but
we don't  is not at the level of the neck so
will have to fight a little to
get our stuff up and accompany his
music because that's it it
works both ways
who
then
the love you have of our characters
it's one thing that  we feel us on a
daily basis and I know that in the
work of writing it is something
which is fundamental we want to do nothing for
free we know that the game can
be very very dark very very hard but
but there is always a reason to  that
's really a form of logic
every time we write something
we do something for requiem
it's when it rings false when it passes
passes and we know that hugo where lives jan
no i wouldn't have said  that I wouldn't have
acted like that and so it's funny because
i  they actually play with us
[Music]